hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of following the Masters
I believe that the fastest and most
effective way to grow a business is to
model the strategies of people who've
already done what you're trying to do so
today we're going to look at how a young
man went against his father's wishes to
run the family business in order to
follow his dreams in the world of sports
he went on to own one of the most
successful franchises in sports history
this is a story of New York Yankees
owner George Steinbrenner and a top
three lessons that you can learn from
his success George Steinbrenner went
from coaching college football the
statement his family's business and
finally only one of the greatest
baseball franchises in history the New
York Yankees when Steinbrenner started
college he chose English literature
which is not what his father wanted him
to do instead Henry Steinbrenner wanted
George to come back I run the family
shipping business after graduating
college George went at the US Air Force
where he would get his first taste of
the business of sports by establishing a
sports program in his spare time George
had no plans on joining the family
business are ever owning a professional
sports team after his tour in the Air
Force was complete he went on to join
the coaching staff in northwestern
university and then purdue university
but family problems would take him away
from what he loved he would get a call
from his father pleading with him to
come home and help prevent the family
business from going under he told me to
get home and get busy recall
Steinbrenner I wish you could have
stayed in coaching my father never asked
that much but when he did it was an
order after successfully saving his
family shipping company and becoming
president of the company within four
years George went against his father's
wishes and left the business to pursue
his love of sports he would go on the by
to Cleveland Piper's an American
baseball league team but the league
would fold after a few seasons George
would then set his sights higher the
next time and by the new york yankees
for 8.7 million dollars in 1973
today the New York Yankees are worth
more than 1.3 billion dollars are the
most successful professional baseball
franchise in history at the same time
making George Steinbrenner one of the
greatest sports icons in history by
refusing to bow to the pressures that
his family put on him to run the family
business Steinbrenner was able to follow
his dreams and become a sports icon to
help you become an icon in your industry
here are three action items that you can
learn for george steinbrenner auction
item number one create a culture once
you start building a team around you
you'll realize how important it is to
build a culture that supports your
company you'll want people who have
different skill sets but all have the
same value system and believe in what
you're doing as a company now when
you're hiring you need to make sure
people fit within your company culture
and don't just have the skills you're
looking for one bad hire can bring the
morale and spirit of your entire
business down so take your time and do
it right George Steinbrenner knew from
the first time he stepped into ownership
with the New York Yankees that he would
have to change the perception or culture
of the team and its fans being the best
meant that he would have to get the best
players and start winning in order to
get the fans who start coming to the
games and back in the team one of his
new policies that he implemented was a
grooming of his players by implementing
a strict grooming policy he would make
sure everyone viewed the Yankees as
professionals he wanted every player to
be poster boys to others could use them
as examples to be the best you had to
look your best this policy was not just
for the players even executives and
other employees of the Yankees had to
abide by these policies according to
Steinbrenner it's an incredible
achievement particularly when i remember
that when i bought the Yankees we had
trouble drawing 1 million to the stadium
we have the greatest fans in the world
winning was everything I don't care what
to tell you winning is the most
important thing in my life after
breathing breathing first winning next
action item number to earn by working
hard you won't find many successful
entrepreneurs he'll tell you that it was
easy to build a big business being an
entrepreneur comes with a lot of hard
work and energy it's going to be more
work than any job you've ever had but
hopefully it's also a lot more fun than
you've ever had to it all starts with
hard work if you're not willing to give
it everything you've got don't expect
anything great to happen one thing that
george steinbrenner believed in down to
his core was that a person can only be
an earner if they worked hard a hard
worker can get themselves out of a lot
of trouble and build a business that is
successful he believed that working hard
could bring along its benefits by
working hard a person can do just about
anything they want and having people
around you that work hard will also make
you even more successful Steinbrenner's
working habits reflect that value system
he worked from home from eight a.m.
until noon when he left for the office
and worked there until 7pm he would make
his last call 11pm before retiring for
the day according to Steinbrenner my
father wasn't a believer in monetary
allowances for my sisters and me so he
set us up raising chickens we sold the
eggs to our neighbors one of our
neighbors one of the fresh chicken then
we also had to kill undress the chicken
every night we had to update the books
and everything we sold and the earnings
would equally split three ways my best
and worst boss was the same man my
father he never and I mean never took I
can't for an answer he taught me the
value system that to this day I have
continued the practice
action item number three make the
customers happy successful businesses
thrive because of happy customers make
your customers happy and they'll make
you successful do whatever it takes to
know your customers understand their
core issues and solve their problems
give them an outstanding experience on
top of it and the lineup to come back to
you and tell their friends the spine of
the rumors and complaints about George
Steinbrenner being a tough boss he did
believe in the fans which he commonly
described as his customers he's one of
the most customer-centric businessman in
the industry more than any other sports
franchise owners Steinbrenner went out
of his way to please his fans and give
them what they wanted there were
numerous ways in which he showed his
fans and he was listened to them first
of all he thought his fans had the right
to watch and support a championship team
that is why who's willing to spend
whatever he needed to to get the best
players and win championships more than
the money however Steinbrenner also
tried to cultivate a culture of proud
New Yorkers according to Steinbrenner
our team played hard but we let our fans
down we will do better we know how to
win as I've always said the way New York
is back us we have to produce for them
own in the New York Yankees is like
owning the Mona Lisa
so remember create a culture earn by
working hard and make the customers
happy to finish up this video I wanted
to share when my favorite true stories
about George Steinbrenner and some of
his best quotes since george
steinbrenner's father did not believe in
giving allowances to his children
georgina sisters were set up in a
chicken business they would sell eggs or
fifty cents a dozen or chickens to the
neighbors to make extra money they would
have to kill the chicken and pluck the
feathers if the neighbors wanted the
buyers chicken to cook he did this job
from the time he was nine years old
until he was 15 when his father would
decide to send him off to military
school however George knew that he'd
have to give up his portion of the
chicken business despite the fact that
it was family he had no problem doing
whatever it took to take a profit he was
a businessman bottom line and he did not
let anyone not even his own sisters
stand in a way of his business
aspirations i sold my egg company to my
sisters for three times what it was
worth he said they've never liked me
since
thank you for joining me for another
edition the model in the monsters if you
like the video and you want to see more
please give it a thumbs up below I also
love to hear what you have to say if you
want to leave a comment underneath the
video and stay tuned for next episode
you